hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner partei ich
stehe heute wieder nicht in meiner küche
sondern ich bin in mannheim und zwar
hier
hab das gesehen der eine oder andere
kind bestimmt auch ich bin heute hier
vom taxi hier geht es nämlich das mit
abstand beste und leckerste boxer war
natürlich habe ich noch nicht überall in
deutschland oder auf der welt back war
gegessen aber mir persönlich schmeckt
sie einfach am besten von dem was ich
jetzt so probiert habe bisher
und ich möchte heute einfach zeigen wie
man bakoa selber machen kann und zeigen
euch einfach mal diesen laden hier und
für euch einfach mal hinter die kulissen
bisher weiß noch nicht genau wie das bak
war erfunden hat sind die türken sind
die griechen oder die araber die
schwaben die schwaben waren es bestimmt
nicht
und ja das ist aber jetzt auch gar nicht
wichtig denn hauptsache es schmeckt und
jeder kultur macht sie ein bisschen
anders und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach
mal wie's drinnen gemacht wird und für
euch herum das taxi umgibt seit etwa
1979 und hier könnt ihr einfach mal
sehen wie toll das schon im schaufenster
aussieht also was ihr alles hergestellt
wird
im innern sieht das ganze so aus es ist
ein schöner kleiner laden wird jetzt
aber auch demnächst umgebaut und
vergrößert und ihr könnt hier die ganzen
ablagen sehen und ich mich jetzt einmal
in die bäckerei nach unten hier könnt
ihr bereits erkennen wie groß das ganze
ist hier seht ihr zum beispiel zu teig
ausrollen maschine den teig habe ich
jetzt nicht gefilmt wie er hergestellt
wurde
hier ist etwas stärke drin und da wird
der teig dann ganz ganz dünn ausgerollt
bis auf 0,05 millimeter und ihr seht es
jetzt auch hier bereits das ist ein
laden in dem hand in hand gearbeitet
wird das heißt ein prozess folgt nach
dem anderen
hier wird der bankberater in form
geschnitten und zurechtgeschnitten und
kann dann auch gleich weiter verarbeitet
werden
wir werden wirklich nur ganz natürliche
rohstoffe verwendet wie ihr hier sehen
könnt pistazien die sind relativ teuer
also da kostet ein kilo pistazien 33
euro die werden hier ganz frisch
gemahlen mit einer besonderen maschine
die ebenso scharf ist in den
messerklingen und soeben das fett in den
westen drin bleibt und nicht aus den
stadien heraus presst mir hat es
natürlich ganz viel spaß gemacht wie man
sehen kann
und da habe ich eben die ganzen
pistazien einmal durch gegeben
es gibt natürlich ganz viele
verschiedene sorten von backpulver hier
wird jetzt eine sorte gemacht da helfe
ich jetzt gleich auch mit
hier arbeiten wie ihr sehen könnt auch
nur männer
denn das ist ein knallharter job ist
erfordert sehr viel muskelarbeit und das
sind hier ausgebildete meister also
oster aus der türkei
wir sind alles wackelte die arbeiten und
hier werden einfach ganz viele
verschiedene formen gemacht die sally
darf natürlich auch mithelfen und auch
ich lerne immer wieder dazu sie werden
jetzt die teigschichten ausgebreitet mit
pistazien bestreut und da kommt
eigentlich zwischen jeder teig schicht
etwas von diesen pistazien mit rein
danach wird es teilweise eben aufgerollt
zweimal und mit schönen ausstechformen
ausgestochen und da habe ich einfach mal
ein bisschen mithelfen
und nach der herstellung egal welcher
sorte werden sie dann durch das fed bad
gegeben das heißt sie werden mit etwas
fett beträufelt mit etwas butter
reinfeldt danach kommen sie in den
backofen und werden dann mit dem zucker
sirup getränkt und dieser ist übrigens
heiß also das ganz heiß gebackene gebäck
wird dann auch heiß mit diesem
zuckersirup begossen und stars dann
einfach abkühlen
ihr könnt sehen in dieser bäckerei wird
mit hochprofessionellen maschinen aber
auch mit ganz einfachem werkzeug
gearbeitet
in dieser bäckerei gibt es natürlich
nicht nur süßes und baklava sondern im
stockwerk oben also wohl auch die
verkaufsfläche ist wird wird auch peter
hergestellt und auch kleine teigtaschen
als auch bekanntes gebäck zum frühstück
oder eben auch zur teezeit
und so sieht dann später die fertige
ablage aus ihr seht schon was für eine
produktvielfalt ist hier gibt und da ist
natürlich für jedermann etwas dabei
jetzt stelle ich euch mal die einzelnen
backnanger sorgten vor
hier könnt ihr schicksal sehen in bagdad
gegen brasilien
die welt total lustig sein
hier könnt ihr noch davis musca sehen
und hedge karte ich habe jetzt meine
gemahlenen pistazien mitgenommen habe
auch ein backblech und das rezept und
jetzt gehe ich nach hause und macht für
mich meint selbst gemacht das backrohr
ich finde jetzt wieder zu hause und
möchte euch jetzt zeigen wie ich meine
backpulver zu hause mache ich werde
jetzt den teig selbst herstellen aber
man kann auch gekauften teilnehmen das
zeige ich euch allerdings mitten im
video also wenn ich dann eben mitten im
prozess den die zutaten sind wirklich
nicht viel also das sind sachen die er
überall bekommt ich habe nur eins oder
zwei exotische zutaten aber die kann man
auch ersetzen bzw frau sie erst gar
nicht
das backnanger video wird es vielleicht
etwas länger aber ich möchte euch
einfach jeden schritt zeigen und habe
jetzt die ganzen handgriffe von dem
meister gelernt und kann euch einfach
die vielen tipps auch mitgeben damit
auch sicher zu hause auch gelingt ich
würde sagen ich zeige mich jetzt einfach
mal alle zutaten also sowohl für den
teig als auch für die füllung und den
sirup und dann starten wir einfach
gebraucht ein kilo mehl drei eier
zehn gramm salz und etwa 300 milliliter
wasser es kann auch sein dass wir mehr
oder etwas weniger brauchen für die
füllung brauchen wir 200 gramm nüsse ich
habe jetzt hier die gemahlenen pistazien
die ich mitgenommen habe ich habe ich
aber auch 200 gramm walnüsse ihr könnt
aber auch haselnüsse oder mandeln nehmen
oder auch einfach alles mischen
hier habe ich etwas butter reinfeldt das
ist jetzt geht das habe ich aus einem
arabischen supermarkt mitgenommen und
zwar ist das geklärte butter sehen
butter hat man ja 80 prozent fett etwa
und 20 eben morgen flüssigkeit und
dieses hier ist reines fett
ihr könnt aber beispielsweise auch
einfach brutal ist also butterschmalz
nehmen für den sirup brauchen wir ein
liter wasser und eineinhalb kilo zucker
etwas zitronensaft und ich werde das
ganze noch etwas aromatisieren mit etwas
rosenwasser da müsst ihr darauf achten
dass es rosenwasser ist was man
verzehren kann das habe ich jetzt auch
aus einem arabischen zuckermarkt
mitgenommen und hier könnt ihr auch
sehen dass man drauf steht dass es eben
zum verzehr geeignet ist
zuerst gehe ich jetzt das mehl auf eine
arbeitsfläche
ich werde das ganze jetzt ohne
küchenmaschine machen ob ich einfach zu
zeigen wie das auch ohne technische
geräte geht
da kommt jetzt eine mulde hinein und
hier gebe ich jetzt meine eier hinein
gemeinsam mit dem salz und verrührt es
ein klein wenig da gebe ich jetzt auch
etwas vom wasser hinein so dass sie das
salz etwas auflöst und dann nimmt jetzt
einfach die hände und knetet vom rand
nach innen immer mehr mail hinein und
fügt dann immer wieder schluckweise
wasser hinzu das ist jetzt natürlich im
prozess des dauert ein bisschen länger
also ich werde den teig gibt es auch
etwa 20 minuten lang kneten bis er
einfach die gewünschte konnte
es hat also nicht so weich sein wie ein
hefeteig und etwas eine festere
konsistenz haben ähnlich wie nudelteig
der unterschied zum nudelteig geschehen
jetzt auch einfach nur darin dass der
nudelteig mehr eier anteil hat und
dieser bug einfach viel weniger anteil
hat also einfach immer weiter kneten
teig wird dann auch immer glatter hat
keine krümel mehr drin und wird dann mit
einem feuchten tuch abgedeckt damit er
nicht austrocknet
ich gebe ihn dann einfach in diese
glasschüssel wieder zurück und ich werde
in dieser zeit einfach meine normalen
und das wegschmelzen
ich würde an eurer stelle immer ganz
ernst nehmen und die dann frisch malen
war dann einfach das aroma viel besser
ist aber wenn ihr natürlich die
möglichkeit habt könnt ihr auch
gemahlene nüsse und gehackte nüsse
nehmen ich gäbe das fett einfach in den
kleinen topf und wertz bei etwas stufe 3
von neuen erhitzen also bei ganz
niedriger temperatur
ich arbeite gleich mit einem zucker
thermometer und kann dann das fett auf
etwa 60 grad erhitzen lassen
ich zeige euch aber auch gleich eine
möglichkeit wie ihr die 60 grad erhalten
könnt ohne ein zucker thermometer dafür
erhitzt ihr das pferd einfach bei eben
geringer stufe und dieses jetzt einen
tipp von mir was ich von dem meister
bekommen habe natürlich dürft ihr das
nur machen wenn ihr ganz vorsichtig sein
und zwar soll tier ist bei ganz
niedriger stufe erhitzen und immer mal
wieder den kleinen finger reinstecken
und ihr merkt dann auch dass das fett
lauwarm wird und irgendwann wird heiß
und der zeitpunkt an dem ihr den finger
nicht mehr drin lassen könnt da habt ihr
dann etwa die 60 grad erreicht und da
könnt ihr das dann ausschalten und eben
auf dieser temperatur lassen so werden
es dann später weiter verwenden
ich würde ich aber raten wenn ihr den
teig selber macht dann bereitet das feld
erst dann zu wenn er das backpulver
bereits in eure form geschichtet habt
ich werde mein partner in einer runden
form backen und zwar ist das so
so ein rundes tablett zum backen aus
edelstahl das habe ich jetzt aus dem
türkischen supermarkt aber ihr könnt
auch einfach eine backform nehmen nur
mit nehmt bitte keine springform weil
dadurch dass wir später noch butter
darüber gießen und da noch der sirup
reinkommt kann es passieren dass eine
springform einfach ausläuft und eine
riesensauerei entsteht deswegen nimmt
auf jeden fall eine form eben die fest
ist und hier keinen offenen rand hat ich
nehme einmal diese große für mainz
selbstgemachtes selbstgemachtes baklava
und diese kleine benutze ich dann um
euch zu zeigen wie man back war aus
fertigen blätterteig oder auswärtigem
baku abheben herstellt und diese formel
müssen natürlich gefettet werden
das mache ich jetzt mit meiner
zerlassenen butter und dann zeige ich
euch wie man den teig ausgerollt dass
ich natürlich auch ein bisschen
anstrengender arbeit aber mit dem
richtigen werkzeug klappt es auf jeden
fall und ich zeige euch einfach auch ein
paar leichte handgriffe das perfekte
pendant war hat etwa 50 schichten und
zwar hat es unten etwa 20 schichten in
der mitte dann die nüsse und dann oben
wieder 25 bis 30 schichten
ich werde jetzt genau so wie eben im
taxi und wie eben traditionell auf diese
weise machen
ihr könnt es auch natürlich aber auch
anders schichten dass ihr zweimal löse
hinein gibt und dass ein bisschen
auflockert ich nehm ich hier meinen
fertigen teig heraus und nehmen diese
schlüssel um deine mischung reinzumachen
zum ausrollen und zwar habe ich hier ein
glas mail und ein glas speisestärke am
besten nimmt ihr weizenstärke ich habe
jetzt auch keinen tag und nehmen einfach
die ganz normale weiß stärke aus dem
supermarkt also meistens ist ja
speisestärke eben weiß stärke und das
hilft mir einfach dabei dass ich die
baklava teil ganz ganz dünn ausrollen
kann und jetzt nehme ich mir einfach
diesen teig und teile ihn in gleich
große stücke
ich werde jetzt jeweils 30 gramm stücke
abteilen und diese zu kleinen kugeln
formen und wird diese dann ebenfalls mit
dem tuch abdecken und ganz kurz ruhen
lassen
so sehen jetzt die fertigen welchen aus
ich habe jetzt in 49 bekommen also einer
fehlt mir das macht aber absolut gar
nicht das ist nämlich schon relativ
viel und ich werde jetzt auch von hier
noch ein paar bällchen hier übergeben
natürlich werde ich in der zwischenzeit
immer wieder diese teig kugeln abdecken
damit sie einfach nicht austrocknen im
nächsten schritt nehmt ihr euch jetzt
ein ganz normales nudelholz kann aus
silikon oder auch aus holz sein und
rollt dieses kügelchen jetzt mit etwas
von der stärke mischung aus so etwa auch
teller größe also ein dessertteller
deshalb jetzt etwa nun durchmesser von
15 zentimetern und wenn ihr hierbei
immer darauf achtet dass teig stück
immer mal wieder kurze zu drehen und
dann weiter zu holen
habt ihr auch immer ein rundes stück als
er dann wird's nicht eckig sondern es
wird immer schön rund und hier lege ich
jetzt immer etwas stärker zwischen die
verschiedenen lagen und kann jeweils
fünf teig blätter übereinander stapeln
und diese dann gleich weiter verwenden
meine tage sind jetzt komplett
vorbereitet und jetzt geht es weiter und
zwar nimmt ihr jetzt eure hand oder
faust und drückt den teig etwas flach
hier könnt ihr auch gerne mit etwas
kraft arbeiten datei kann ja gar nicht
zusammenkleben weil ihr her genug stärke
mit hinein gegeben habt das macht ihr
wieder auf beiden seiten damit sich der
teig auf beiden seiten vergrößert und
dann nehmt ihr wieder den aus hollstadt
und vergrößert diese teile einfach diese
fünf schichten auf einmal das könnte
jetzt natürlich mit diesem nudelholz so
weitermachen bis der teig die optimale
größe hat oder wenn ihr euch einfacher
machen wollt und wenn ihr die
möglichkeit dazu habt nehmt ihr euch
eben ein anderes gerät
stattdessen verwende ich jetzt so einen
aus hollstadt das heißt opfer war auf
türkisch und zwar ist es einfach ein
holzstab der hatte zu etwa und
durchmesser von 15 zentimetern
wenn ihr sowas nicht habt könnt ihr euch
auch einfach irgendwas langes nehmen
eben rundes zum beispiel ein rundholz
mit dem durchmesser oder mein papa hat
zum beispiel auch meiner mama mal aus
einem frischen besenstiel und clever
gemacht weil sie das so dünn nicht so
gern mochte und sie hatte dann einen mit
zwei zentimetern durchmesser und es
könnte jetzt einfach verwenden damit
macht man in der türkei auch ganz gerne
eben die ewv karte damit sie sehr dünn
werden und mit dem werde ich jetzt
meinen baklava teig ausrollen
wenn ihr mit dem opfer arbeitet wickelt
identitäts ganz fest um den stab und
dann streichelt ihr den teig von innen
nach außen also ohne großen kraftaufwand
sondern einfach mit der leichten hand
bewegung immer von innen nach außen
streichen und so vergrößert sich der
teig dann automatisch dann bietet immer
wieder auf versetzt den teig und legt
ihn wieder an so dass eben der teig
nicht oval oder eckig wird sondern schön
rund bleibt und das macht ihr einfach
bis er die optimale größe erreicht habt
ich verwende dazu ganz gerne mein blech
natürlich als orientierungshilfe weil es
ja da reinpassen soll
und es darf einfach ein bisschen größer
als das blech ausgerollt werden
dadurch dass wir jetzt immer fünf
schichten aufeinander haben geht es
natürlich viel schneller und viel
einfacher ihr könnt gerne auch etwas
mehr schichten nehmen aber mit fünf
schichten finde ich arbeitet sich ganz
optimal weil die schichten so daneben
nicht so sehr reißen und ihr auch kein
problem damit haben dass sie mit
aneinander kleben die ersten 20
teigschichten sie jetzt fertig und ich
werde jetzt in mein vorbereitet das
blech geben und ihr könnt jetzt einfach
so nehmen wie sie sind und hier
einsetzen
hier gebe ich jetzt meine pistazien
drauf und wie gesagt könnt ihr da alles
mögliche nehmen alles was euch am besten
schmeckt und jetzt dürft ihr einfach
noch die restlichen 29
hupka blätter also baklava tiger hinein
schichten
und zwischen die letzten partei
geschichten gebe ich noch etwas von
dieser flüssigen butter damit das schön
aufgehen kann da oben und das ist jetzt
die letzte schicht geschmeidig ist auch
hier ab
und die letzte schicht wird jetzt hier
auch reingesteckt am rand
jetzt muss das backpulver macht
geschnitten werden hatte zuerst von
außen bis in die mitte da kommt man gut
rein und dann einmal wenden und den rest
durchschneiden um raten zu erhalten
nämlich dieses blech jetzt nicht ebenso
orthogonal sondern nimmt etwas diagonal
und schneiden wir jetzt hier noch die
raupen zu recht
ich habe mich jetzt doch dazu
entschieden das ganze etwas kleiner zu
machen
und jetzt dieses flat welches jetzt etwa
60 grad hat einfach rüber dann müsste
halt wirklich großzügig sein
ich glaube man sieht es mir an wie
anstrengend das jetzt wahr
und so sieht das backen war jetzt bisher
aus und das darf jetzt bei 180 grad ober
unterhitze den open habe ich schon vor
bereits für etwa 30 minuten in den ofen
die oberfläche sollte jetzt schön gold
coin werden und in dieser zeit zeige ich
euch wie man das baklava mit fertig in
bagdad gemacht
hier seht ihr jetzt einen fertigen
bagdad eib und zwar kann man das für
backwaren benutzen aber eben auch für
barrick gold es jetzt 500 gramm
diese päckchen war einfach im türkischen
supermarkt oder auch im deutschen zu
knacken muss eben diese marke auch schon
gibt und ihr seht dass ich ähnlich aus
wie solche blätterteig eingewickelt in
seinem in the back wohl hier in seinem
backpapier und die sind richtig dünn
ausgerollt und alles sehr gleichmäßig
aber eben auch sehr trocken aber das
macht ja in dem fall gar nicht ihr seht
mal wie dünn die sind fast wie
pergamentpapier und hier verfahren wir
jetzt ein bisschen anders geht aber viel
viel schneller und es ist viel arbeit
sparen und zwar habe ich jetzt hier
meine eckige backform ihr könnt
natürlich auch noch unternehmen müsste
dann eben rund zurechtschneiden und ich
lege mir jetzt die backform einfach oben
drauf und schneidet das bak den bug
einfach erst mal zu
so den rest verteile ich auch direkt
der unterschied ist jetzt dass wir jetzt
zwischen den einzelnen blättern das sind
übrigens etwa 40 oder 50 sogar der
unterschied ist einfach dass wir jetzt
zwischen die einzelnen lagen einfach
auch schon von dieser flüchtigen butter
streichen müssen weil es ansonsten nicht
durchdringt und das ganze viel zu
trocken wird und eben auch nicht
knusprig wird also verfahren wir genau
wie vorhin jemand nur zwei drei blätter
hinlegen streichen oder ihnen sogar
übertroffen
jetzt nehme ich hier auch die sätze
teilten blätter die könnte jetzt nämlich
hier prima hinein geben ohne dass man es
eben sieht und etwa bei der hälfte gebe
ich jetzt meine wahllos vermischung
hinein und ich habe hier noch zwei
teelöffel zimt hinein gegeben weil ich
das ganz gerne auch so sind ich mag was
mit dem rest abdecken
oftmals steht den türkischen rezepten
dass das gebäck heiß sein soll und der
sehr kalt sein soll
das kommt einfach daher weil eben die
hausfrauen sage ich jetzt einfach mal
oftmals nicht wissen wie die konsistenz
von dem sirup sein was von dem oster
also von dem meister habe ich mir sagen
lassen dass beides heiß sein soll also
das perfekte backpulver und das
professionelle partner wird so gemacht
dass der teig ganz heiß ist frisch aus
dem ofen und das bei sirup eine
temperatur von 100 3 grad in etwa hat
dann hat er nämlich die perfekte
konsistenz
während unser back dabei im ofen markt
können wir schon mal den zuckersirup
vorbereiten
dafür habe ich jetzt einfach den zucker
in den großen topf gegeben gebe auch das
wasser hinzu und für gleich ein paar
tropfen zitronensaft hinzu das hilft
einfach dabei dass der zucker und dieser
xerox später nicht karamellisiert und
jetzt wird es einfach bei mittlerer
stufe etwas erlebst irgendwann könnte ja
auch sehen dass die der sirup klar wird
weil sich der zucker dahin auflöst und
dieser sirup muss jetzt eben heiß sein
in vielen haushalten wird es so gemacht
dass bei dem hausgemachten bakuba sirup
kalt verwendet wird damit das backpulver
nicht matschig wird aber dieser meister
hat mir erklärt dass es einfach auf 103
oder 104 grad erhitzt werden muss und es
dann die perfekte konsistenz hat ihr
könnt euch jetzt natürlich ein
thermometer zu legen oder einfach das
ganze auch kochen so drei bis vier
minuten kochen lassen abschalten und
dann sollte es die perfekte temperatur
haben
und so darf das backwaters stunde lang
ziehen
ich würde sagen er zwei stunden einfach
bei raumtemperatur lagern so dass der
sirup komplett eingezogen wird
unser heutiges butler sieht jetzt so aus
und ich finde es sieht richtig gut aus
ist es mittlerweile schon sehr spät
geworden ich habe auch ungefähr um 16
uhr damit begonnen 16.30 war mein tag
fertig und bis sich dann komplett fertig
war war das 20 uhr also bist bei beiden
backbleche da sehr gut drauf war nehme
ich jetzt einfach mal eine gabel und
dass butler war durfte jetzt so etwa
zwei stunden fast also eineinhalb er
durchziehen das braucht ja auch
unbedingt
und so sieht es jetzt dann bei mir aus
es geht jetzt auch bei mir ist es nicht
voll getränkt mit zuckersirup man sieht
auch jeder ist unten drin nichts mehr
übrig ich mag das aber einfach auch
nicht wenn dazu viel drin steckt also
ich hatte hier 45 voller kellen voll und
man kann natürlich auch etwas mehr
nehmen dann ist natürlich auch etwas
füße und das andere sieht im inneren und
das andere sieht so aus also da habe ich
etwas mehr sirup mit drin
ihr habt jetzt also gesehen wie ich
meine back maurer gemacht habe ich hab
die tipps von dem türkischen meister
bekommen und war da auch sehr dankbar
dafür
ich habe zwar früher auch schon abba
kurras selber gemacht aber so mit diesem
wertvollen tipps war das natürlich umso
besser und ich weiß nicht vielleicht hat
der ein oder andere auch ein anderes
rezept für baklava oder eine variante
vielleicht seid ja aus verschiedenen
ländern und könnt da einfach mal eure
tipps weitergeben oder eure
geheimrezepte und ich wünsche euch auf
jeden fall ganz viel spaß mit dem rezept
alles gut
hast dich in die wange gebissen ich
würde mich natürlich freuen wenn ihr mir
einen kommentar last und auch eine
bewertung und ihr könnt auch gerne ein
rezept von stahl lassen
ich werde in nächster zeit etwas mehr
zeit habe angewiesen du isst gerne teil
ja ich werde in nächster zeit etwas mehr
zeit haben und kann da eben ein paar
videos mehr machen auf jeden fall
wünsche euch noch alles alles gute und
mal warst du aber jetzt nicht mehr ins
bett ja dass dies auch noch aber jetzt
nicht sehen